a huge victory for britney spears this
afternoon
her fans went wild cheering and yelling
as news broke that her father jamie
spears has been suspended from her
conservatorship her lawyer matthew
rosengart also told the court that he
wants this conservatorship to end with
an orderly transition i'm not happy i
can't sleep i'm so angry it's insane as
for brittany's state of mind well before
today's hearing a source told et that
britney sees this phase of the
conservatorship as quote the fight for
her life and she feels really close to
winning it
so how exactly could britney transition
out of this long-running conservatorship
this morning before the hearing i spoke
to an expert attorney tamar armanek she
represents actress amanda bynes's mother
lin in her daughter's conservatorship
have you seen conservatorships end
successfully before
i have but it is very difficult and it
requires a lot of support brittany
really needs to feel that support that
at any given moment she can reach out
and her team will be there
of course there's another major factor
in all this the media frenzy the press
in the media my whole life you know
there's it's really crazy because one
minute
they tear you down and it's really
horrible and the next minute you're on
top of the world
just since friday three major new
brittany projects have aired some of
their explosive claims involve
prescription drugs we have direct
evidence that
her medication the medication that she
liked to take
was increased if she worked a recording
device in the singer's bedroom and an
alleged secret letter that brittany
wrote in 2008 she brings it up she's
constantly threatened that the
conservators will take her kids away no
matter who you are the judge is a human
being and now in the last few months the
judge has realized there are so many
eyes on this case
we're told that britney is quote
definitely affected by the documentaries
bringing up her past but she also
acknowledges that they are fueling the
free brittany movement
[Music]